[Musique]
alors nous sommes devant l'UFR St ve la
faculté de médecine de 50 ans témoin de
l'importance de la santé sur ces
territoires François Morton bonjour
bonjour Patrice vous êtes le maire de
guillancour vous êtes vice-président de
la Communauté d'Agglomération en charge
de la politique de la ville de la santé
et de la solidarité je disais oui il y a
une forte application he de 50 ans en
matière de santé notamment à travers le
le contrat local de santé oui alors ce
contrat local de santé il a il a trois
axes essentiels le premier c'est de
fonctionner comme un observatoire du
territoire comme une veille santé en
quelque sorte le deuxième c'est
d'améliorer les parcours de santé
notamment pour les populations les plus
vulnérables et enfin et bien évidemment
et tout le monde le comprendra de
développer l'offre de soins sur le
territoire et alors il y a aussi une
réflexion commune avec tous les
personnels de santé pour définir cette
politique ils sont effectivement très
nombreux et très divers sur le
territoire de C absolument alors témoins
de cette coopération et de cette
ouverture et bien c'est la maison de
santé pulerie disciplinaire et
universitaire de montigi alors Allin
Jami qui est à la fois mcin généraliste
mais aussi directeur départemental de
médecine générale à l'uf va nous
présenter cette maison de santé qui a
cette par particularité d'avoir un
ancrage
universitaire la maison plu
professionnelle montinil Bretonneux
c'est une structure universitaire qui
regroupe neuf cabinets de médecine
générale qui regroupe des infirmières
qui regroupent des des sages-femmes des
psychologues des kinés des
diététiciennes des orthophonistes le
principe reste le principe universitaire
c'est-à-dire le le soin l'enseignement
et et la
recherche on peut solliciter nos
patients pour participer à des actions
de recherche en médecine générale et ils
peuvent être sollicité pour par exemple
remplir des questionnaires à la suite
d'un traitement voir comment ils l'ont
vécu comment comment ils l'ont
interprété dans leur quotidien voilà
donc les patients s'attendent à ce que
on ne fasse pas que du soin ici on fasse
aussi de la recherche et qu'on les
implique dans ces processus de recherche
et que parfois on mette nos étudiants en
avant et c'est fréquemment qui
consultent des internes en fin de
formation don qui ont les compétences
pour pouvoir dispenser ses soins en
étant supervisé par les maîtres de stage
qui sont
ici
entre les remplaçants les assistants on
a au moins une dizaine d'étudiants qu'on
a vu transiter dans nos cabinets pendant
leur formation qui sont soit vraiment
installés en tant que titulaire d'un des
ne cabinet soit qui sont assistants il y
a encore aujourd'hui des DIN Montin des
gens de la ville nouvelle qui n'ont pas
de médecin traitant ils sont
relativement nombreux puisquon les a
recensé à peu près à sur rien que sur
Montini 4 500 et si on pouvait avoir
deux médecins de plus
on résolvrait de manière assez efficace
l'accès au
[Musique]
soin le regroupement qu'il y a eu ici a
permis de maintenir l'offre de soin
c'est on a déjà des collègues qui sont
partis à la retraite dans ces trois
dernières années qui ont été remplacés
c'estàd qu'il y a pas eu de en dehors de
la structure les gens qui partent pour
l'instant ils sont pas remplacés ici les
gens ont été remplacés les étudiants
qu'on rencontre quotidiennement quand
les on les interroge ils nous disent ou
moi mon exercice ça sera pas tout
seul c'est important de de pouvoir
réunir euh des professionnels de santé
dans un même lieu hein oui alors je
j'imagine que vous faites allusion aux
maisons de santé hein évidemmentoui il y
en a trois sur le territoire déjà alors
je vous confirme il y en a une à Guill
en courour une à trappe et euh la
troisième euh à Montini absolument
l'universitaire deux sont en projet déjà
bien avancé hein à plaisir et aux clés
et puis trois en projet un petit peu
plus lointain mais elles verront le jour
c'est certain alors c'est important
c'est un levier important effectivement
pour pour lutter
contre ce qu'on appelle parfois de
manière très générale les déserts
médicaux mais mais effectivement c'est
un levier puissant alors ça n'est pas le
seul mais c'est important de de
permettre à des médecins de travailler
ensemble effectivement de se soulager
aussi d'un point de vue administratif he
c'est important et puis de pouvoir
échanger vous parlez des déserts
médicaux
euh malheureusement je crois que tous
les territoires sont un peu atteints par
par ce phénomène évidemment il y a des
spécificités selon les selon les lieux
même même à l'intérieur de de de la
communauté d'agglomération absolument
sur les 12 communes alors on on n pas
les mêmes offres de soins que l'on soit
sur montinig en cours par exemple ou sur
la verrière qui encore ne dispose
d'aucun médecin généraliste par exemple
hein donc il y a de réelles disparités
au sein même de cquenttin au sein même
de saquentin alors un des acteurs
fondamentaux de cette politique de santé
vous en parliez d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure c'est l'Institut de promotion de
la santé euh c'est le service de santé
publique de de de 50 anselent le bras
armé de la santé bras armé je crois qu'
réunit 21 partenaires et justement sa
responsable Anne bland nous le
présente alors l'Institut de promotion
de la santé c'est le nom qui est donné
au service Santé de C Yveline qui met en
place la politique de santé sur le
territoire c'est à la fois un accueil
spécialisé en promotion de la santé et
c'est aussi un équipement qui va
héberger une vingaine d'acteurs qui sont
associatifs ou hospitaliers et qui vont
ensemble mettre en place une offre de
santé gratuite préventive et
d'accompagnement vers le
soin les habitants de Saint-Quentin
peuvent venir se faire vacciner
gratuitement ils y trouvent également
des consultations de dépistage et de
diagnosties des infections sexuellement
transmissibles un service également
d'accompagnement et de soins pour les
personnes qui présentent des conduites à
risque autour des addictions avec une
consultation spécifique pour les jeunes
consommateurs des bilans de santé
également à titres préventifs qui sont
proposés des bilans de santé complets
avec des entretiens avec dentistees
généralistes travailleurs social pour
l'accompagnement vers le parcours de
[Musique]
soins on sait que les jeunes ont été
particulièrement éprouvés par la crise
sanitaire et que les je dirais les
stigmates de cette crise sont encore
présents chez beaucoup d'entre eux donc
on a une offre qui est assez riche dans
le domaine de la santé mentale à travers
l'antenne du lieu écoup de jeune à
travers la maison des adolescences
sududivilines et on l'a renforcé
dernièrement par un nouveau dispositif
porté par la Fondation fr qui consiste
en fait à recruter des services civiques
qui vont être formés spécialisés un peu
sur les questions de santé mentale pour
aller les rencontrer d'autres jeunes du
même âge et d'aborder ces questions de
santé mentale de manière à pouvoir
sensibiliser mais également peut-être
identifier qu'il y a peut-être chez les
jeunes rencontrés des troubles de santé
mentale qui ont besoin d'être
accompagnés et ces jeunes ambassadeurs
en santé mentale vont également pour
pouvoir informer sur l'offre locale s'il
y a un besoin de mettre en place un
accompagnement
[Musique]
adapté accompagner les aidentss c'est
aussi une priorité qui a été développée
par l'Institut de promotion de la santé
pour des publics qui sont souvent
invisibilisés qui ne se reconnaissent
pas forcément comme aidant et en tout
cas qui sont souvent isolés par
l'accompagnement qu'ils apportent dans
la durée auprès de leurs proches malades
ou en situation de handicap et cet
isolement nous a fait réfléchir à la
mise en place d'un certain nombre
d'actions de soutien aux aidans qui sont
itinérantes dans les ville de
Saint-Quentin pour être au plus près des
besoins qui sont
recensés François Borton il y a une
dimension qui est apparu assez récemment
en tout cas depuis la crise de la covid
c'est la question de l'état psychique de
la population la santé mentale vous avez
constater ça sur ce territoire oui alors
vous avez raison de remettre cela dans
la chronologie c'est-à-dire c'était une
dimension
importante avant la crise sanitaire ça
l' est devenu encore davantage avec la
crise sanitaire pas simplement chez les
jeunes et donc on s'est aperçu en en
examinant les besoins sur 50 an en
iveline évidemment que cette santé
mentale elle devait relever d'une
nouvelle structure voilà d'accord c'est
ça c'est c'est ça c'est les les les
grands axes de cette politique c'est de
trouver des structures pour répondre à
ce besoin c'est ça voilà nous avons créé
c'est très récent ça ça quelques
quelques jours quelques semaines à peine
donc nous créons le premier contrat
local de de santé mentale sur 5tin en
Yveline qui réunit les 12 communes de
l'agglomération l'agglomération nous
sommes ici dans des grands amphis de
l'UFR si Bonell qui est un établissement
d'excellence dans la formation des
personnels médicaux justement le josran
qui est son doyen va nous le présenter
parce que c'est à la fois une faculté
importante et c'est un élément
d'attractivité du
territoire l'fr en chiffre c'est près de
8000 étudiants étudiants paramédicaux
étudiants médicaux maotiques sag-femm et
médecine c'est également 450 enseignants
chercheurs et puis enfin 11 équipes de
recherche pour certaines dans des tops
mondiaux vraiment de de très haut
[Musique]
niveau l'UFR a la chance d'être sur le
territoire de Saint-Quentin qui est
extrêmement riche en entreprise
entreprise notamment avec un fort
potentiel de de développement et de
recherche donc nous devons nous
rapprocher de ces entreprises travailler
avec elles qui pour nombreux d'entre
elles sont des groupes internationaux d'
d'autres sont de taille plus modeste
mais elles peuvent toutes revêtir un
intérêt pour nous pour travailler sur
des projets communs qui amèneront là
aussi à de la création de valeur et à du
développement économique donc je pense
que l'UFR a a vraiment ce ce rôle
d'amener des professionnels de santé sur
le territoire et des professionnels que
nous formons de participer au projet de
développer l'économie sur le territoire
et et puis nous devons aussi nous
investir dans une logique également de
de prévention et le projet de centre
d'innovation pédagogique intègre
également une plateforme qui visera à
assurer un rôle de prévention tourner
vers les habitants de
[Musique]
5 le centre d'innovation pédagogique
Simone veille santé est un projet qui
vise à développer la simulation en santé
c'est-à-dire que nous allons former nos
étudiants non plus au lit du patient
comme on a l'habitude de le faire depuis
depuis maintenant des décennies dans les
études de santé mais au contraire quand
tu auras un geste à apprendre quand il y
aura une manipulation à apprendre sur un
mannequin par exemple donc ce qui fait
que on est dans une logique qui est
communément appelée le jamais la
première fois sur le patient donc c'est
quelque chose d'important qui maintenant
tend à se généraliser nous avons déjà
développé cette cette formation ici sur
l'UFR mais il faut que nous
l'élargissons parce que nous avons de
plus en plus d'étudiants c'est
l'objectif de ce centre d'innovation
pédagogique de formé par la simulation
d'avoir également une plateforme qui
elle sera tournée vers les entreprises
et le développement économique à travers
ce qu'on appelle un Living Lab donc là
qui va permettre à des start-ups à à de
jeunes entreprises de nous rejoindre
dans ce projet François Morton on a
parler de l'implication de sa-quentin en
matière de de santé le contrat local de
santé justement il va J en 2024 alors
quelles sont les les perspectives pour
l'avenir alors d'en faire un un autre
évidemment donc il va se poursuivre donc
on va faire une analyse des besoins
durant toute l'année 2024 en
interrogeant les communes en se servant
aussi de notre tableau de bord qui sera
réactualisé en 2024 pour connaître
exactement les besoins des habitants de
Saint-Quentin et d'essayer de trouver
les meilleures réponses possibles merci
beaucoup François Borton merci à tous et
puis à très vite pour un nouveau numéro
de
skimag